[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i did stand up for the second time at
whitney cummings house
whitney cummings
uh had a stand-up comedy show in her
driveway or her basketball court really
her driveway area this guy you see you
know you came to that later to make
movies didn't you
you wanted to change the world now some
psychotic rich [ __ ] got you filming
her friends at a basketball court
ain't that the way you know whitney
knows all these uh influencers like
these instagram
is the proper term hoes
probably not i'm kidding ladies
but these instagram and well the teats
are out
i mean
they're not influencing people to go to
school
they're not doing a lot of adult
literacy programs from my understanding
i'm sure they have
many philanthropic endeavors but you
know a lot of it is the teats are out
and uh and they all have like
deals you know they're hawking body oil
for millions and millions of dollars
on injury it's not my demo really i'm
gonna do well because this is my demo
you know people with body oil deals uh
that's what really relates to what i
talk about people with 20 million dollar
face cream
endorsements i like a working class
family from outside of philly that
begrudgingly has to sit in a car
together for 25 minutes everyone's
smoking cigarettes including the dog
on the way to the show
angry people people that feel like
they've been slighted
my audience is people that feel like
they've been slighted like me because
both of my parents survived 9 11. happy
9 11 too those were the good times
remember 9 11.
though you didn't know it then but that
was remember going on fridays hugging
people that was the [ __ ]
none of you care about 9 11. don't get
soft on that you didn't do [ __ ] after 9
11. and then all of this attitude you
said these hot instagram people have
this attitude they're like
[Music]
i said they talk like
i love this crowd because no one has a
job like do you realize that no one in
this crowd has a job
the disney channel girl had one but no
one else has a job like everyone else
just
loafs around that everyone's job in this
crowd is to say hello to 20 million
hello
hi
what do you do for a living i say hi
i defend chrissy teigen
um i'm kid i don't think she's eating
kids i don't think she's but yeah i
don't i don't know but i don't think she
is
she's not twitter too much you know she
doesn't have the time but
it takes work the sawing of the leg
i'm kidding many of you are like oh no
it's getting weird
this is so fun i had fun
in the middle of my set i said oh good
crystal lee just got here
i said he'll go next
that didn't get a big chuckle
that was a ve that was not a warmly
received joke oh julia just got here
good
it's fun it's topical the point um
this is his crown though
it's an influence or heavy you know they
don't relate to these people
um spade was there whitney was there and
the book or the comedy store was there
and some people were bombing by the way
you never really want to bomb when you
have people that you respect there but
some people just i mean wow
uh but most people doing great annie
letterman murdered killed it very funny
but annie's like that she can kind of
[ __ ] bob and weave and really
you know when you're in a weird me and
annie came up in new york when we're in
a lot of weird situations
and you had to
len give yourself over to that as a
comedian and just go we're in this
[ __ ] up situation we're gonna call it
out i love that whitney has more of a
budget than all of comedy central
it's amazing like this is a better
production than a comedy central half
hour
center that foul right now is just a guy
taping you with his phone
literally this is such a tremendous
production and then miranda cosgrove
who's on icarly
i don't want a pedophile what is this i
don't watch these things
nickelodeon
drake and josh what are we nuts
where are the adults where's candace
owens
where is the exhumed corpse of william f
buckley i want to perform
you knew someone that had it
was it bad
no it was life
[Laughter]
was it long did they lose their sense of
smell
what a fun group to do crowd working
fun group here
nobody can really respond you know
everybody's in industry everyone has
crowds of part like a one-person
industry
they're like i don't know who is this
pig i don't know
i don't know what this pig wants
hey
we're instagram influencers we think
with our tits
what are you doing here
can you [ __ ] talk to us
can you [ __ ] i don't know who these p
olivia mun i don't even know who these
people are kesha who what's that what's
a ketchup
i don't even know what that is
is that like shakshouka
is that it's a dish
who is this kesha
she said hello she because i'm kesha
like i'm going to turn around i'm a huge
fan
she said that to me i had a peach in my
hand i go do you think this is ripe i
was hitting it on the counter
she's a singer apparently
she did that song tick tock tick tock
that was the song of every fat freckled
irish beast woman
who will still put it on facebook and be
like remember fridays and college at
suny new paltz with my girls
tech talk you know
it was every fat slobs theme song who
was trying to get a [ __ ] in their ass at
3 a.m
at a suny school in new york freckled
irish beast women
would listen to that song that is what
you've inspired casual yes or yes who's
next
spade who's going up next
no one olivia martin who's doing it
who's here kesha is casually gonna do
one-liners what if kesha just got up and
did racist one-liners and murdered
[Laughter]
yes you want hot people dancing to your
music but it ain't that's not the case
you know who loves that song me and a
wig
me and a
wig and they'll still put it up on
facebook
and they go hey this was a song from me
and my girls remember girls and they tag
all the other [ __ ]
hot air balloons
that they went to a suny school with
these [ __ ] boats
that they went to school with i'm
tagging all my girls and then you just
you just you click on the the women that
they've tagged and it's just someone
whose face is like
you know the fat woman instagram shot
i've done it many times it's from up
here
up here tilted head that's fat woman
instagram up here tilted head you don't
know what's going on beneath my head
i bet it's hot though
i bet it's a cauldron of [ __ ] juice
that's what she did tucker there's a
place downtown
tick tock whitney always ridicules the
skin things that i you know try you know
i have a deal with a a very advanced
skin you know
cream called cortisone
[Laughter]
with hello
[Laughter]
and i always come over here and she
ridicules me and she gives me like you
know whatever bad seam and concoction is
spent giving her 30 000 to put in a
[ __ ]
and
but i was uh i was really glad that i
was included now and now i'm sure i
won't be again
thank you for watching this video if you
enjoyed this tim dellen edit please
consider subscribing to joke world right
now and if you really like this tim
dillon edit dm us on instagram and we'll
send you some of these free joke world
stickers no questions asked they're free
they're sticky thank you for watching
again we'll see you tomorrow with
another video comedy news update number
17.
[Music]
you